boo blackhead podcast
special guest what up about to kill this
uh freestyle man my guy emilia rojas
been a minute it's been it's been a
while since you've been on the show i
feel like uh it was awesome you're on
the show because when you were uh with
the one week notice it was a couple
years jesus did they do it did they do
another one of those they did it was
like uh
they did a whole new crew like a whole
new
we i don't know who was a part of it
dole man was a part of it
right i don't know who else was a
problem i think that's the only person i
know who was a part of it yeah uh there
was a kid with dreadlocks long dress
he's he's dope too i'm blanking on his
name i don't know but the first one was
the one yeah that was the fight you
audio push
dizzy dizzy jaren benton demrick
yeah hoppa kato just all y'all in the
same world we [ __ ] it up bro it was
though
yeah let's get to the bars bars
bars
run that [ __ ]
come on come on yeah
right town
[Music]
they made the women have babies but then
they can't buy formula of the
supplements a long way from suffrage
they suffering it seemed like the glue
that held a culture together they
started huffing it they got a government
that's working against us with hurtful
agendas where people live on curbs and
intent and we don't even know what's
next it's a world of suspense they see
the dollar falling fast savings earning
you less dog lately i've been learning
i'm blessed since i started shifting
focus to myself i'm not concerned with
the rest they see the tattoo lettering
that curve on my chest and they assume
that i'm the worst they could get
because i'm everything they fear i'm
highly educated not accredited meaning
that i'm smart but i don't owe no
college debt for it they worst nightmare
bilingual and intelligent and highly
motivated so they know i'm never
settling dog they wouldn't let us into
carnegie mellon so we sold them same
drugs they got their pharmacy selling
black or brown with drug offenses then
they call you a felon but if you white
they just call it rebellion
that's the narrative accepting it's
imperative the wrong shade will change
you from a shooter to a terrorist the
wrong last name will make a refugee an
alien and ice won't even let our own
natives in but justice ain't blind not
ambitious hate to see me winning i made
something out of nothing like a 3d
printer and i come from out the gutters
i was knee-deep in my sin to survive
never seeing me repenting i'm cool as a
fan haters never peep me vent and i move
with the fam i'm only where my team get
letting don't care about the ground my
name don't even need be mentioned i'm
craving power i ain't craving attention
i'm as close to perfection as you can
get i'm done being humble young mestizo
[ __ ] with the blood of the
jungle i got family in la finca i got
cousins that hustle so it ain't rapping
if i talk about a [ __ ] tunnel
i'm talking trafficking i'm talking cia
backing it i'm talking reagan funding
the contracts with kilo packaging and
they were handling the substances is
hazardous they learn the metric system
even though they ain't do math with the
dog i got a homie drowning sorrows and
an activist i'm torn between my cash and
me trying to be an activist we worship
money that's a sacrilege rocky smart he
got rihanna pregnant he don't gotta rap
again these fashion women love to look
at themselves i bring a chef to gaiukaku
i don't cook for myself and i don't give
a [ __ ] about you why don't i look
through your veils and fake strings that
you buying just to push up yourselves
look numbers lie that's why i'm not
impressed them a anrs will start to call
they see you flying on jets they want a
link to talk with me about what i got
next i ask them it's the roi on the time
i invest this time is money in a meeting
with you that's about an hour skip the
[ __ ] put me in touch with who got
the power if you can't look at me in the
eye then you a coward and it's not some
[ __ ] that you should be proud of
i see my ops use my name bravely and
they fronting like we fan but i know
they hate me these clowns ain't killing
[ __ ] ain't john wayne gacy make me wanna
choke a [ __ ] i feel like i'm wayne
brady let it go whoa
that's what we're here for emilio i hold
you a good verse bro i told you i owed
you some fire i know you just watched a
crazy freestyle we got another one
coming next week presented to you by lrg
don't forget to use my promo code at
l-r-dash g.com go to their website it's
in the description below and use the
promo code bootleg you'll save 30 off
and they just drop these look at these
basketball shorts boys these things is
crazy
you know what i'm saying lrg's [ __ ]
back
so why don't you go ahead and uh go get
you some 30 off right now